you married the gentleman me say his
name right David CASP yeah who created
happy endings yes and and he also
created your new show marry me and so
you guys got married yes despite the
phone issues and my anger issues we have
to pick a wedding photo here which is
nice this shows you seconds before you
threw that bouquet at someone at 700
miles an hour wrestled him to the ground
you invited Oprah to your wedding I did
I invite over to all major events wait a
minute don't know Oprah that's correct
[Laughter]
that's great you so you would just
invite her Thanksgiving I invited her I
think I have a photo oh you put out you
put out you set a place for her okay I
think they have that there Wow classy
wedding she's a ghost relative I got a
creepy that you always have a chair set
for Oprah I know oh she's here now we
always leave that space for Oprah I
don't have an address for her I sort of
just address it to the universe and I
assume she I assume she's gotten you
know she's very busy
yeah what do you mean do you actually
you mail an invite somewhere no it's
more of just a thought
you know I feel like with Oprah you just
kind of put it out there and it might
come back to you okay you're criminally
insane I'm just making a list here
things the throwing yelling the pulling
things out of a wall the invisible Oprah
I'm a real piece
you